hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today we are talking
about
some news uh it feels like it's been a
little while since there's been like
some kind of breaking news that i really
really wanted to talk about but this
particular topic is something that i've
covered pretty extensively interviewed a
lot of developers about
um ultimately something i found very
very predictable but i wanted to
add some more context to it than i know
of than what most of the
outlets that are you know covering it
just as basic news have spoken about but
we'll get to that let's just get to the
article first i'm reading this from
pc gamer this one is written by andy
chulk and the headline is ubisoft is
going to focus more on high-end
free-to-play games in the future
aaa releases will continue but ubisoft
sees a great opportunity to expand its
audiences through free to play it goes
on to say when ubisoft announced last
week that its next division game called
heartland will be free to play we
wondered if it was a sign that the
publisher was pursuing the success that
activision had enjoyed with free-to-play
battle royale
call of duty warzone the short answer is
yes it is
but its ambition is not limited to tom
clancy shooters
ubisoft chief financial officer said
during today's earnings call that the
company's previous commitment to release
three to four premium
aaa games per year is no longer a proper
indication of ubisoft's value creation
dynamics which is the most business term
in the world but
other publishers have been doing this
for quite some time and
uh there's this fascinating activision
earnings report um presentation
that uh i read maybe four three four
years ago
that just highlighted all of this stuff
to me so specifically they had this this
one slide that was about value per hours
essentially
it was saying that the games industry
someone can pay
60 70 for a game obviously depending on
your region shout out to all my friends
in australia you're still paying like 90
to 100
out there but that you can put you know
hundreds of hours into the game and then
if you divide the amount of money
someone spent on the game versus the
amount of hours that they put into it
that the games industry is earning less
money per
hour of consumption time than other
entertainment industries
like for example if you go see a movie
and it costs you 15
that's two hours for that amount of
price so their goal
with that presentation was to figure out
how to monetize individual player hours
in a smarter way
or in a way that is more indicative of
other industries i'm not saying that i
agree with this or that i want it i
don't
but i do think it's helpful for pretty
much anyone who's interested in the
video game industry
to know the attitudes that um
encourage these kinds of changes or
announcements or discussions on investor
calls
where free to play uh tends to mean that
even if the game is free to play
literally it is free to buy that players
are more
likely to uh monetize the individual
hours they play in a way that the
publisher deems more
fair fair it doesn't seem like the right
way to put it they are profiting
massively from this stuff
it's so hard to make any kind of excuse
for you know the games industry needing
to raise prices or go free to play and
increase their loot boxes when the
ceos are getting million dollar bonuses
but
still basically that's the idea behind
that is that with free to play it tends
to be easier to
monetize a product on an ongoing basis
that is more closely related to the
amount of hours that someone is putting
into the thing that they're playing
rather than just getting the one
flat fee 60 dollars you now get
sixty dollars a year it's so wild that
fifa gets to do that and have ultimate
team
and this and i have a whole thought
process about the negative impacts that
ultimate team specifically has had on
the industry because
i'm getting off track here the way that
so many of these decisions are made is
in comparison to other things that are
successful so like
if anything in ea's repertoire of games
is not
the same as ultimate team and it's not
making the same amount of money as
fifa's ultimate
team which for anyone who doesn't know
is basically a system where you buy
players you buy cards in in random packs
and then
you just keep putting money in to build
up this team that you want
essentially ultimate team being so
successful and so incredibly profitable
does mean that every other ea game is
under pressure to perform as well as
ultimate team or could be seen as a
failure
uh by investors and this also obviously
influences every other facet of the
industry they look at their competitors
they look at how much money
the other publishers are making and why
they aren't making that money and it
just influences trends and i really do
think ultimate team
have a big hand in that back to the
article so ubisoft said that they will
continue to maintain
a high cadence of content delivery
including powerful premium and free to
play new releases
the goal is to grow audiences by
widening our brand at the top of the
funnel in other words convincing more
people to try ubisoft's games by making
them free at the entry level
which i don't believe um
i'm sure that will work but i
i i'm more inclined to believe that this
is about figuring out smarter ways to
monetize than just by growing their
already astronomical audience
though i do wonder if uh game pass has
had an influence on this
immediately game pass even though
obviously it is a subscription service
effectively makes
all of those games free to play not
technically you are paying for it
but it does mean that you can try
a game without knowing if you would play
it otherwise because you don't feel a
huge
loss that's the benefit of free to play
so there isn't this barrier to entry
i think that's really good in a lot of
ways i think game pass is very helpful
for people with disabilities as a very
good example
is they don't know if they can play
certain games a lot of the time the only
way for them to find out is by trying it
and sometimes to try it costs you
seventy dollars
just to find out you can't play a game
like i feel like that's heartbreaking
but you know it's also just very helpful
for low-income families like there's
there are a lot of benefits to that
but i also know and have seen a lot of
developers speak about
the uh increased in
downloads they've had even after the
game pass period so this
is uh mike rose he works at no more
robots they publish descendants yes your
grace hype no space outlaw not tonight
and let's build a zoo and he tweeted
this
on may 7th he said two years ago today
descend has launched on xbox game pass
since then over four million people have
played the game across xbox game past pc
game pass and xcloud
and we just renewed with xbox so
descenders will continue to be on game
pass for a very long time to come
which i assume means xbox just gave them
more money
uh mike shared some additional stats in
relation to game pass
game pass downloads in the second year
were much higher than the first year
this is the
player base over the last 12 months so a
steady increase
we now see more than one million
sessions every single month
essentially uh very positive for normal
robots
the amount of player engagement that
they have for descenders now
is very impressive and lends to them
being more likely to
make a sequel or even get funding for
games to publish elsewhere but mike's
just one example of
uh you know dev speaking really
positively about game pass which
is kind of like free to play and that's
why what i mean is like i wonder if
ubisoft is seeing
things like this and being like okay
well we're aaa but
can we tap into this market of people
who otherwise wouldn't play this
downhill motorbiking game which
seriously descends is fantastic i really
like descendants you should totally play
it
but i wonder if that has an influence on
this and the timing of this happening
right now
especially where it seems like xbox is
heading in the direction of selling that
service
um and you know other publishers are
definitely getting on board with their
own services that it's more about the
subscription service that gets you a
bunch of things
rather than individual games because i
know we are seeing a trend
people are overall buying uh less games
uh but are putting more hours into the
individual games that they buy so
for ubisoft who's releasing three to
four games a year again i think i only
play one ubisoft game a year if they
were still doing stuff like child of
light and valiant hearts i would be
all over it but their games are so long
and to me feel so formulaically like
similar
that i get like ubisoft fatigue i think
uh related they did also announce
today that skull and bones has been
delayed again um and i wonder if that's
to go into this different kind of
remodel situation where they want it to
be free to play and they're trying to
change that approach maybe i'm not sure
but yeah the idea is like to make sure
that you monetize
individual lesser games to make them
last longer to make sure that they
really are games as service and then you
monetize the individual hours put into
those rather than trying to sell
multiple games and
in some cases competing with yourself i
think is where all this is coming from
okay back to the article it's a
financial decision of course it is
ubisoft ceo yves gamer said the
company's revenues are more and more
recurring referring to players
purchases within games that are often
free to play and their growing
importance compared to single purchase
premium games
but dugwet i'm not sure how to pronounce
his name
that's the chief financial officer so
the company is not looking to cash in on
low budget work we are building high-end
free-to-play games
to be trending towards triple-a
ambitions over the long term and this is
interesting one ubisoft gets a lot of
criticism for
you know rehashing things and there is
currently a perception that free to play
means low quality that is also a
perception with game pass for sure
um that i feel like the publishers are
all gonna have to kind of band together
to break out of if they
want to lose that perception because
that's certainly what exists right now
it's an interesting one because if you
ask me would i be more likely to play
next year's assassin's creed game if it
was free to play
the answer is no my issue with
those games at this point is more that
again the formula and the time
commitment
um but i do think it makes sense for
ubisoft to have you know people
pick pick whichever one they want and
just play that one a lot and focus on
engagement on individual
uh free to play games rather than trying
to across the board make people buy
every single one of them but you know
they have had micro transactions in
their their recent games in any case so
um i wanted to go on and talk about this
because i don't know anything about this
it says the hyperscape acknowledgement
is interesting in case you'd forgotten
the free-to-play sci-fi battle royale
launch last year
was released in 2020 and almost
immediately fell off the map i remember
like people talking about it for a week
that's about it but there's no doubt
that free-to-play games can be highly
polished and incredibly lucrative as
games like call of duty
and warzone and apex legends have
demonstrated also i think warzone
from what i heard from people in the
industry
it did not take them very long to make
and that's a really appealing part of
battle royales
is that you can make them
very quickly because you don't actually
have to provide the amount of content
again when speaking in terms of hours
that people will play them for because
other players provide the content so
like yes you have to have a nicely
crafted map and interesting heroes and
ways to keep people engaged interesting
weapons of course
but you don't actually have to provide
like 100 hours of content because the
people who are dropping in
provide the changes in gameplay and the
content
not that difficult to make in the grand
scheme of things because you don't have
to provide
you know a certain amount of hours of
entertainment
you just let players do it for you uh
hyperscape missed the mark but the
familiarity of the division should give
heartland a big leg up and if ubisoft
continues
that strategy across game series like
assassin's creed watchdog spark right
and tom clancy's everything even bigger
changes on the free-to-play scene could
be
in the offing i think this is going to
happen so this is uh
another part of this that people were
speaking about today this is from a
tweet from jeff keely that says video
games evolving and changing
just 26 of ea revenue came from premium
sales the rest was from live service
dlc mobile and micro transactions that
is
wild to think about uh but obviously the
same
can be said for you know rockstar i
would think it's the same
for ubisoft quite interesting responses
here fortnite did figure it out paris is
right and fortnite does continue to
provide a lot of content but
not my kind of game so this is generally
my stance what peter glagoski said here
that sounds really awful to be honest i
don't want more micro transactions
i keep saying micron i don't want more
micro transactions in live service
nonsense i'd like classic linear games
with a concrete ending and
no bloat for the record i strongly agree
and we can dig into that a little bit
too
this is an article that i wrote in june
of 2019.
um this is the most important part this
is for ign
obviously that's me uh it says
developers say twitch is hurting
single-player games but they're not
going to disappear nobody panic
um again this is really a direction that
we've been heading in for quite some
time
is more free to play more micro
transactions more live the service from
our big
publishers especially the big third
party publishers but i don't think that
the market for single player is going to
disappear
um that is still important to a lot of
people that's still the games that i
tend to prefer to play
and where playstation and nintendo
specifically are concerned because those
companies from my perception want you to
buy hardware
let me move this over because they want
you to buy the switch they want you to
buy the playstation 5. they need to have
incredible experiences that you can only
get there um that are not necessarily
online
so room for single player games is still
absolutely there oh look at me
2018 writing about enormous
single-player successes like god of war
i work there now
apparently the notion of single-player
games being dead i haven't read this
article even though i said
i wrote it goes back to mark sonny the
lead architect of the playstation 4
saying right now you sit in your living
room and you're playing a game by
yourself we call it the sp
mission or the single player campaign in
a world with facebook i just don't think
that's going to last and i don't think
he's wrong
and this is a part of this that i found
to be super interesting um
so when i was like trying to piece this
together um about like the death of
single player games that's what i was
interviewing people about and so i had a
lot of different perspectives i ended up
going with this angle because that was
the thing that was the most
significant or the one that i found the
most surprising or the one that i felt
like nobody had really heard about
before and it was ultimately that even
from indies or triple a's
uh people said that twitch was having a
really significant impact on what game
studios were choosing to make
uh we got a quote here from rami from
flambe who said one of the most
underdiscussed effects of twitch youtube
let's play the whole
content creator ecosystem on the games
industry is how the marketing impact of
those platforms has affected what kind
of games developers make why would any
major studio outside of a first party
trying to sell consoles which is kind of
what i was saying before about why i
don't think you need to worry about
playstation or nintendo or a studio with
a reputation for single-player games i
guess that also counts i don't think
that um
someone like don't nod or remedy
uh is gonna go off and start making
live service games uh why would they
bother with an immersive single player
campaign
they are really expensive to make so
this goes on to talk about you know sony
continuing to fund single-player
narrative-based experiences
selling hardware hardware platform
loyalty but it is worth mentioning that
even back to these stats
um every game in the top 10 selling
video games of 2017 was multiplayer
focused
with the exception of the legend of
zelda breath of the wild and horizon
zero dawn
which have that exclusive pull so i mean
multiplayer games are selling damn well
um and again this is the thing i said in
2018 this shift in focus could mean we
get fewer but higher quality single
player experiences
as more publishers move towards online
experiences ubisoft being a great
example
so wild look back on that with games
like foreign siege and wildlands
the appeal and importance of
single-player games that do pop up is
higher i maintain none of this means
single-player games are dead they still
do
very well god of war got so many views
on youtube
um and on twitch it just it still worked
really well for content creation i don't
think those games are going to go
anywhere i think there are a lot of
developers at major studios who want to
make those games i personally want to
make single player games
i don't think they're dying i don't
think they're going to go anywhere
not completely but i do think and it has
already started to happen that new
ubisoft's your activisions your
blizzards
um really all the third-party publishers
are more incentivized to make live
service video games free to play makes
perfect sense to me because they're
getting rid of the barrier they're
getting rid of the competitive barrier
effectively people don't have to play
pay to play it there is less competition
versus every other studio
and every other game that they're
bringing out like i said the focus is
probably more likely that they want you
to play their same one game for a really
long time
rather than playing a wider swath of
different
games and uh sharing it around through
different publishers it's kind of a
cause and effect it's not just something
the publishers are doing you know of
their own accord it's also that
the publishers have been encouraged to
do it based on the players spending
habits based on the hours they spend
on these games based on content creators
obviously with i feel like the closing
note of this whole thing being it's just
really hard for publishers who have
investors they need to please to argue
that a single player game is going to be
more profitable overall than something
that's likely to get thousands of hours
of free marketing
free marketing on twitch and more hours
played from individual players a lot of
whom are also on twitch
but you can really get rid of the twitch
part and just stick to this it's hard to
argue
that a single player game is going to be
more profitable overall that's really
the end of it so yeah just something
that um i really find interesting to
talk about
um i do dislike this trend i prefer a
single player game i feel very fondly
about single-player games i try to talk
about them very often
but i don't think they're dying i don't
think they're going to disappear
we're just less likely to get them from
third party publishers
specifically that is it for me today
everyone i hope you found this at all
interesting or informative
i will see you guys next time bye